voilà pour les réparer ça passe par la
réparation chirurgicale mais faut que ça
aboutisse à la réparation si j'ai un
brûlé champeaux a brûlé mal dans sa peau
pour ouvrir aux super héros ats c'est
julie aujourd'hui je vais vous emmener
avec moi dans tout la reconstruction et
le parcours de soins des personnes que
l'on appelle des grands brûlés pour ceux
qui ne connaissent pas je suis moi même
une grande volée bon je pense que ça se
voit
j'ai été brûlé sur 40% du corps au
troisième degré quand j'avais 16 ans et
de l'hôpital en passant par la
rééducation je vais vous montrer toutes
les étapes par lesquelles on passe pour
se reconstruire en tant que grand boli
[Musique]
déjà qu est ce qu un grand brûlé
comment on est pris en charge finalement
quand on a une brûlure grave c'est ce
qu'on va voir aujourd'hui on est à
l'hôpital saint louis à paris et on va
dans le service du professeur minutes
c'est parti d'une procédure en la
personne de concilier à une personne
comme étant un grand
moi je considère tous les gros
détaillants rougier qui nécessite un
traitement spécialisé maintenant il ya
des brûlés qui sont tellement grands que
le pronostic vital est engagé à court
terme un grand brûlé c'est quelque chose
de difficile à évaluer le pronostic
vital vers le pronostic fonctionnel le
mouvement et puis elle pronostique
esthétique morceau logique c'est dire
que la brûlure c'est une seconde avant
on rit et une seconde après la
trajectoire de vie julie suis désolé
nasa est complètement changé il faut
remettre tout cela et on y va
ce fait sien c'est un jeune homme qui a
été brûlé à 30% quel âge il est 17 ans
17 ans voilà donc normalement montchamp
pronostic vital n'est pas engagé ou peut
engager s'est jamais vraiment peut
jamais dire mais le pronostic
fonctionnel et esthétique et gravement
engagés dans le symbole est très grave
alors là du coup on va devoir se mettre
en tenue ce qu'on peut pas rentrer dans
la chambre comme ça je vous expliquerai
la chambre en même temps c'est trop vous
de me dire que l'âge et la culture
indien mais qu'il ya six ans du coup
j'étais à la place entre guillemets du
jeune homme qu'on va aller voir et je
vais voir en fait comment on change des
pansements comme on s'occupe d'un
angolais alors voilà ça s'appelait pas
quand vous dites à manger des membres ou
que le veut ah oui et évidemment
d'auteur évident que j'ai n'ont ils pas
il faut que je passe déjà pour moi
personnellement et n'ont cédé refusent
de poster sur leur sort
donc là on rentre dans la chambre donc
là c'est très très codifié on se dit
jeunes les mains ensuite remettre le
chapeau et port du masque voilà vous
êtes prêtre pour rentrer
[Musique]
la chambre kim salle de réanimation
un bloc opératoire 1 chambre cas si une
chambre de balnéothérapie quand on les
touche regardez le nombre de personnes
qu'il faut juger
c'est une équipe qui doit être
absolument soudé si on n'arrive à rien
pour l'instant du coup en train de
préparer tout le matériel pour essayer
de fermer assez rapidement pour
occupation de cendres patron température
doit d'abord mettre les lunettes qui lui
sert de tulle braque une interface sur
la brûlure et ensuite on va remettre des
compresses qui sont arrivées de produits
antibiotiques ou antifongique ou autre
et après on va recouvrir tous avec des
bonnes pour que tous se maintiennent
bien entre le début du pansement et la
fin du pansement ça peut durer entre une
heure et deux heures voire plus si
jamais le pansement se passe pour brûler
elle agit comme un toxique sur le corps
et elle va dégrader les organes comme on
lui contre ça il faut enlever au plus
juste là pour rouler qui fait qu'à un
moment donné on arrive à ce qu'on
appelle nous couvrir le voulait salir vu
faire une grèce et lui remettre une peau
de manière à ce qu'ils vivent alors il
ya des autos grèce lire on prend de la
pochaine passion les mêmes qu'on va
replacer sur les tailleurs ou apprendre
une couche très très minces de pau et
cette couche très très mince on va la
pause et ailleurs et elle apprendra si
on peut aussi la rentabiliser c'est à
dire l'ex pendra laurent la place dans
une sorte de moulinette
on les tire comme un barresi quoi et à
ce moment là on va avoir une peau
beaucoup plus grande avec des tas de
petits trous comme si c est un petit
plaît quand vous transformer une plaie
comme ça qui va aux cicatrices en trois
mois en mille petites plaies d'un
centimètre les manchots cicatrise trois
jours
amanullah au coup de
ça fait comme en valeur
j'ai services en
engage à la john est ce que du coup pour
y expliquer pourquoi on plonge un
patient rien comme artificiels
l'anesthésique pendant les pansements et
qu'on les projetant des comas
artificiels souvent pour gérer le début
la phase parlant très friable et puis
petit à petit on essaye au maximum de
les faire revenir avec l'oeuvre qui
participent aux soins moi je me rappelle
très bien par exemple c'est horrible on
a l'impression que nous arrache la pole
littéralement et si on nous endort pas
derrière ça crochet par une grève sont
toutes récentes il a été greffé il ya
quatre jours chez ce monsieur y aura ici
le deuxième temps à faire qui au niveau
du dos ce qui va faire le va faire dans
le même temps la face antérieure et la
presse postérieure
donc c'est monsieur lyonnais pour que
quelques amendements
[Musique]
quand on est en grands brûlés l'hôpital
finalement c'est que la première partie
de la reconstruction on doit réapprendre
à marcher à manger à parler et à
accepter surtout son corps à accepter ce
qu'on est devenu tout ça ça va passer
par de longues séances de kiné et
dargaud thérapie afin de retrouver tout
simplement son autonomie pour vous
montrer comment ça se passe on vous
emmène au centre de rééducation couvert
en région parisienne c'est parti
[Musique]
bon je vais donc la première salle c'est
la salle de kinésithérapie où on va
effectuer essentiellement imposture
massage dermique lpg et puis la seconde
salle de rééducation du service et la
salle d'ergothérapie on va s'occuper
plus particulièrement de l'autonomie des
patients tous les appareillages demain
les cons formateur ok le principe de la
biothérapie c'est devant le patient
autonome qu'est ce qui va se passer
qu'est ce qu'on va faire on va faire de
l'étirement cutanée d'accord au niveau
des lois donc je vais posture et la main
de façon à ce que monsieur puisse de
mieux en mieux fermer les de ma course
et de rééducation qui est très
répétitives davantage mêlée qui est
importante
donc là je maintiens la vendra donc
servait d appuyer les contrats puis et
en fait quand on arrive en fin de
rééducation
on a quasiment leurs mouvements
complexes et une rééducation qui est
nouveau d'où l'importance des
médicaments est-ce que ça voilà
[Musique]
est ce que vous pouvez faire maintenant
je vous combien de temps passé
pendant vingt minutes
[Musique]
tu es devant l'objectif le cas laissez
plus tard iv quoi afficher exposé la
motion dont la rage dans la voiture
qu'ils étaient impliqués n'ont s'est
impliqué à 100 si les projets toujours
du culte et sont dans le même temps le
dollar baby
ouais là maintenant et qui sans retard à
buner d'avoir exposé la plutôt sur la
fin de la rééducation à l'intervention
tu sens de 6,3 en portant les mots c'est
à dire en fait ça mais ça vaut la peine
donc là quand je des postures forme qui
peut mentir parce que le sang est resté
un peu beauf et avec nos différents
contrats puis repasser du coup de
salzbourg
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon ça me rappelle beaucoup de
choses et je sais que deux fois c'est
dur mais tu verras ça par la tête quand
on travaille l indépendance de la
personne mon ergothérapie il ya quelques
spécificités du à la brûlure il ya
l'appréhension du regard de l'autre un
surcoût du coup les moyens c'est
d'accompagner le patient venir déjà
prendre soin de sa propre peau on peut
aussi d accompagner à l'extérieur à
savoir l'inversion de commercial
en plus il n'a qu'un pouvoir après de
retour au centre de rééducation en
rediscuter de poker spéciale en fait
c'est bien henri busser moi j'ai été
confronté sans l'aide de personne c'est
des choses que j'ai pris seul de ces
gens s'agitent hôpital mais j'ai été
confronté à tout ça sent mieux j'avais
préparé en fait non le c'est hyper
important
après ça va être encore une autre étape
plus de sortir cette parenthèse on peut
voir se confronter dans son propre
quotidien est belle mais ça et prépare
quand même pas mal quand on a un grand
bouillon peut faire face à des réalités
douloureuses comme celle du regard des
jambes pendant le retour à la vie
quotidienne ou celle tout simplement de
la réinsertion dans la société trouver
un emploi et on a parfois l'impression
d'être seuls au monde
mais heureusement grâce à des personnes
comme une orange lui-même grands brûlés
et créateur de l'association dorn smile
on peut trouver des solutions aux
meilleurs
j'ai découvert un monde de personnes qui
ce 4l ne montrent pas leur c4 et ça font
tout pour ne pas les montrer
là j'ai vu comment que iliad et il
fallait faire quelque chose
pourquoi à ton avis ils brûlaient sont
invisibles
le choc devant le miroir fait que
certains qu un monstre ouais des vins le
premier réflexe est de se dire je ne
pouvais pas sortir du cadre familial
estime de soi mais il ya aussi d'autres
combats il ya un combat financier qui
est très lourd faut savoir que se
soigner quand on est brûlé ça coûte très
cher il ya un reste à charge qui est
très très élevé et puis il ya du réseau
social de la discrimination
professionnelle et qu'on est indicible
voilà si personne n'en pas les
assurances les hôpitaux où tout ce qui
est laboratoires pharmaceutiques ne
s'intéresse pas à la cause donc on se
retrouve à devoir payer bas des
logements cure thermale on se retrouve à
devoir payer nos crèmes qui sont
nécessaires à notre circulation
il y à une vingtaine de centres de
traitement des brûlés en france
pourquoi il y en a si peu et pourquoi
des fois il faut faire 100 km 200 km
pour se faire soigner parce que ça coûte
très très cher et en plus c'est très
long la reconstruction
donc tout ça c'est un coup tu sais que
c'est très dur de d'avoir les
financements
toto finalement tout le monde s'imagine
pouvoir avoir un cancer un jour mais
personne si marine est brûlé un jour
chaque parcours est différent chaque
histoire est différente mais tous les
grands brûlés se retrouve finalement
dans ce parcours on part maintenant à la
rencontre de mélina qui et comment une
grande bruller et on va voir finalement
toutes les difficultés que cela peut
représenter quand on est une jeune femme
bonjour
est ce que tu peux nous raconter va-t-on
nice torture j'ai eu un grave accident
de travail
j'étais en apprentissage installateur
thermique mon patron m'avait laissé tout
seul chez lui et il m'avait demandé de
faire une soudure
malheureusement je n'avais pas de
protection sur moi à part mon pantalon
de travail et mes chaussures de sécu et
malheureusement j'ai pris feu donc il
fait du reste et au mois en feu - 5 10
minutes j'ai été héliportés directement
à la personne
je suis resté trois semaines et demie
aujourd'hui du côté brûlé sur 20% chez
volet sur l'emprunt au troisième degré
et 2e profond franchement il ya eu des
moments c'était c'était vraiment
compliqué c'était des moments du terme
en question jeudi en faveur en fait
j'imagine de commandes qui savent
évoluer
ben je savais pas du tout comment elle
était déjà de base et c'est dans les
pansements on se réveille à l'effacement
et du coup c'est pas commencé en dessous
c'est vraiment une fois que tu enlèves
les pansements que tu vois vraiment doté
bull c'est quoi le plus dur c'est plus
le regard des gens parce que quand la
personne ne connaît pas forcément les
gens ils vont être obligés de
de se demander ce que sur toi alors que
quelqu'un qui connaît du mois là c'est
parce que si tu connais quelqu'un tu va
raconter l'histoire et pas forcément ils
vont le prendre différemment
on a vraiment la poisse oms de passer
pour une bête en fait c'est ça c'est
compliqué on a vécu des situations bien
totalement similaire du coup on a des
grands brûlés mais ballester quoi ça les
regards hagards regarde les gars faut
arrêter ça faut arrêter voilà ces genres
mais brûlé on est comme tout le monde
ces feux qui a laissé ses marques
seraient mal voir par exemple qui a été
touchée vers de la poitrine comment
abordes ça comment tuer franchement ça
me gêne pas mais on avait quand même
envie de poser la question aux
chirurgiens et chirurgien il m'a dit que
c'était beaucoup trop compliquée en fait
et du coup j'ai accepté l'idée de me
dire qu'il fallait que je vive comme ça
et puis ça me dérange pas ouais voilà
franchement ça me dérange pas du tout
même aller à la piscine et tout ça je me
suis dit il faut que je montre aux gens
parce que si je le fais pas maintenant
je le ferai jamais jamais obligé d'être
forte en fait on n'a pas le choix on n'a
pas le choix on doit se relever et on
obligé d'être forte
mais je pense qu'après c'est ce qu'on
disait supérieur on prend conscience
aussi l'importance et de la valeur des
choses sans plage 10 du conte avec terme
allemand vous avez surmonté en fait tout
ça donc même déjà on a un point de
culpabilité sachant que menacer un
accident de travail que le matin même
elle se sentait pas très bien on se dit
avec des si on refait le monde
si on avait su on n'aurait pas envoyé
travailler il faut avoir les épaules
solides
parce que il faut continuer à les
travailler on n'a pas le choix
même en sachant sa fille à des à
quelques centaines de kilomètres de chez
eux de nous et que et qu'on peut pas
aller forcément la voir tous les jours
si nous on n'est pas positif elle peut
pas l'être
on a un lien qui unit les parents les
enfants et si l'enfant sans que vous
vous n'êtes pas bien il va très vite le
sentir et il va se laisser
voilà voilà c'est pas chose évidente
mais malgré trousse un combat c'est un
combat de tous les jours j'ai pu vivre
en fait ce qui se passe de l'autre côté
j'ai pu me mettre à la place de mes
parents j'ai pu me mettre à la place du
personnel médical qui s'est occupé de
moi et c'était vraiment une expérience
incroyable là on n'était pas ça mais li
na qui c'est accepter il faut savoir
qu'il ya des jeunes filles dans le même
cas que mélina dans le même cas que moi
qui ne s'acceptent pas qui ne sort pas
de chez elle et qui se cache c'est pour
ça que je vous demande juste un peu plus
de tolérance si jamais vous croisez un
jour un grand brûlés dans la rue
dites-vous juste qu'il est comme tout le
monde qu'il a surmonté un terrible
combat et pensait surtout à toutes les
épreuves par lesquels il a pu passer
[Musique]